♪♪
(Food sizzles)
(Typing on keyboard)
♪♪
Neil Cross:
In common with the rest of the
world,
Covid was profoundly disruptive
to this show.
Neil Cross:
We were in Mexico City,
filming episode 5,
Neil Cross:
when things got really bad.
And we had no idea if it was
gonna be possible
Neil Cross:
to film the rest of the show.
One of our principal characters
is a teenage boy.
And I was terrified that by the
time we got to re-man in 2022,
Charlie would be
Neil Cross:
6'5", with uh, a lumberjack
beard.
We're very lucky that we figured
out a clever way to come back to
shooting,
Melissa George:
In a bubble, in the safest way
possible.
Neil Cross:
We picked it up in Guadalajara,
five months later.
This isn't how it's supposed to
be.
I know, but it is what it is.
Neil Cross:
I'd always wanted to have a
story where
two characters have
to cross the city on foot
against time.
Neil Cross:
I just wanted to write
a thrilling chase.
Neil Cross:
But with the kids I want to do
something a bit different.
Mexico City is the most
fantastic city.
Neil Cross:
And it's that kind of what do
you get to do
Neil Cross:
when you're a teenager in a city
like that and your parents are gone.
I've never been to Mexico
before.
Gabriel Bateman:
It was a culture shock at first.
I've been trying to learn
Spanish, which has been kind of
hard, but it's been fun.
Do you like chocolate?
Gabriel is, he's just hilarious
because he, he really does
have that energy
Justin Theroux:
of a fourteen year old boy.
He has energy to expend,
he's constantly, you know,
picking at things.
Justin:
And obviously the way Charlie
is written is, he doesn't want to see flaws in his father.
Dina, by contrast, sees
nothing but flaws.
Neil Cross:
She does not wanna be like
Allie.
Dina's tragedy is that she is
I think she yearns for that
normal life so she can just get
a sense of what it's like
Logan Polish:
outside of her dad.
Dina:
Charlie, you don't want that.
-Huh
(All talking)
Dina:
You bourgeois, hipster
dilettantes...
Okay okay.
Come on.
Gabriel Bateman:
Logan and I have a great banter
that we started at the beginning
Gabriel Bateman:
and we have a really close bond,
so I thinks it's nice
Gabriel Bateman:
to have someone to hang out with
on and off set.
Uh and that really comes off as
like a sibling dynamic onscreen.
You can't.
-This is fun.
I wanted to write a story for
a young American man
Neil Cross:
where we see a boy on the cusp
of manhood.
Charlie has very skewed ideas
about what it is to be a man.
Neil Cross:
And I'm very interested in that
fearful desire to be able to
Neil Cross:
prove one's masculinity through
violence.
Neil Cross:
We see a crucial moment in the
real beginning of Charlie's journey.
Neil Cross:
The kid's got a gun.
♪♪